hi there Steve here i am going to
continue as much as i'd like to rant on
things political that I come across
every day in the newspaper I'm going to
stick to language learning for now and I
want to talk about something that I
think is extremely important in language
learning and that is what I call
cultural weightlessness and that means
that to be successful in learning
another language you have to be able to
not think of yourself as belonging to
any particular language or culture your
own language and culture doesn't matter
I'm not an English Canadian learning
Russian I am just Steve I can be Russian
I can be Chinese I can be French I want
to be part of that group I don't think
about what my culture of origin is this
is extremely important you know I
referred to it in my book the book that
I wrote five or six years ago called the
way of the linguist a language learning
Odyssey which is available at amazon by
the way and it's also available at the
link dot-com website and i made many
references in my book two drones a-- who
is a Chinese Taoist philosopher and I
can't say that I understand everything
that he writes but I one has an
impression from reading some of his
parables and the basic gist of his his
approach to life is that we achieve more
through effortlessness and through the
repetitive practice of something then we
do through the deliberate pursuit all
uptight following rules trying very hard
and this is very true for language
learning very true and and part of this
effortless ists effortlessness comes
from from being willing to absorb the
language not resisting the language and
it's surprising how many people do
resist the language the language that
they're trying to learn and I refer to
this in my book and drugs has this nice
parable about the butterfly where he
dreams that he was a butterfly then he
wakes up and he doesn't know whether
he was drawn to dreaming that he was a
butterfly or a butterfly dreaming that
he was drunk or something about effect
in other words to a large extent for
many things we can be what we want to be
and in particular this is true in
language learning now I don't believe as
I've said many times that some people
have a natural ability for languages I
mean to some extent that may exist but
it's not decisive it's not crucial I
don't believe in this business of and
and it's typically the people who don't
put the effort or put the time and I
shouldn't say effort the time into
learning a language who don't try who
say well I don't have an ear for it I
don't believe it I don't believe that
all Swedes and all Singaporeans have an
ear and an ability for language which
let's say Americans don't have I just
don't believe that that is part of the
genetic makeup of any people what does
happen is that the cultural ego of
Swedes and Singaporeans maybe less they
don't necessarily see themselves
primarily as part of Swedish culture
they're quite happy to absorb other
cultures and I see this when I lived I
saw this when I lived in Japan those
North Americans I was a small number
mind you but who were happy to mix in
with the Japanese who wanted to do
things Japanese who weren't hung up
about being American they learned to
speak and they learn to speak very well
so cultural weightlessness extremely
important more important certainly than
the teachers more important than the
grammar it's the willingness to see
yourself as part of that other culture
and and we see this i mean it's
play-acting we see how actors I've seen
American actors who i mean i'm a native
speaker of english and i thought they
were British I thought they were from
London and they because actors are so
good at projecting themselves into the
role that they're playing they're no
longer who they are in real life they
are the role that they're playing and we
have to have that kind of an attitude
when we go to learn a language
comfortably
when I when I was in Japan living in
Japan I would be in meetings with
Japanese people 10 japanese people and
me I mean I didn't see myself as
different they may or may not I don't
know have seen me as different from them
I just saw myself as a member of the
group and we were all speaking Japanese
and I picked up on the way they were
speaking and that became part of how I
acted and and to some extent we can
exaggerate this I mean if I'm going to
speak French I'm an enormous your power
in macomb a moon le pas that's the way
the French are there a little bit
argumentative when I'm Japanese I'm a
little more kind of a vague its oldest
nação Commission I go more gakuto so
Donna so you kind of want this and that
you know if I'm on if i'm listening to
economically and I hear the Russians
argue and they're so dramatic and yet
[ __ ] you know it's this way and it's not
that way and and they have the you know
on this website FMS key which are highly
recommends one of the best language
learning resources anywhere and it
prevents presents such a varied picture
of Russia where you are allowed to
listen to the raving imperialist who
wants to recreate Zara's Russia and you
can listen to the Communists and you can
listen to the fellow spouting Putin's
line and you can listen to the dissident
for who for whom everything in America
is great and everything in Russia is bad
and you can hear all these different
points of view and they talk about
history and stuff so you get a real
flavor and you want to belong to that
I'd love to go to Moscow and sit down
with the people of a Hamas be around
hopefully not too much vodka and and get
in with them so it's that sense of
wanting to belong of seeing yourself as
part of another group and not being
overly hung up about who you are you
know I've it's I would see North
Americans in Japan and they'd meet mr.
Kotter umpteen times they would hear his
name pronounced cattle but it's written
k ay t 0 so therefore he was Cato he was
always Cato because they couldn't get
out of that sense that if it's k ay t 0
therefore you know everything has to be
pronounced the way it's written in my
own line
you have to leave that behind I often
think too that East Asians you know
they're so concerned about their own
uniqueness all the time the number of
times in Japan people would say well
Japan must be the most difficult
language in the world as well no not
necessarily the Koreans are the same way
and the Chinese very disappointed if you
tell them that in fact their language is
not so difficult in fact all kinds of
people go there and if they have the
right attitude they get right in there
and they learn to speak with very little
accent so much so that that they appear
on local television they become a bit of
a freak show here's this foreigner who's
done the amazing impossible thing of
learning to speak Japanese or Chinese
very very well not a big deal if you
want to do it if you're willing to take
yourself away from your native culture
and project yourself into the culture of
that other group you know in Reverse I
think as I say East Asian sometimes have
trouble with that because they're so
determined to be unique you know our
history is unique everything is unique I
mean when you talk to Chinese people
they talked about their 5,000 years of
history as if that's some kind of fact
well it's a bit of a digression but
there is nothing particularly important
that happened in China 5,000 years ago
that that somehow is the starting point
of China there was no China then there
is an oral history of the Shah dynasty
which is 4,000 years old so we could
talk about the beginning of a dynasty in
a very small part of what is today China
in a very smart which eventually
expanded and expanded and expanded to
become today's China but that was four
thousand not five thousand and there are
artifacts and archeological diggings
that go well beyond five thousand years
as there are in Mesopotamia in Turkey in
Central America along the Indus Valley
in Crete in Europe and so forth so
there's nothing unique there but to them
it's very important 5,000 years of
history and therefore and the more
they're hung up in the uniqueness of
their own culture the less able they are
to project themselves into this other
language and that makes them less
capable language learners I don't say
that blanket all East Asians are less
capable language learners but those that
are successful from those
countries are the ones that are able to
leave behind their culture that doesn't
mean that you leave it behind
permanently doesn't mean that you stop
being who you are in fact learning
another language often makes you more
fond of your own culture but it means
that while you are learning the language
and while you are speaking the language
you're able to project yourself you're
able to pretend you're able to play act
you're able to abandon and you're not
waving your flag you are another person
so cultural weightlessness the ability
to project into another language
extremely important for language
learning I look forward to your comments